over my career I spent a lot of time
thinking about the state of education
and it really what brought it to mind
was as I was trying to hire very highly
technical resources and I couldn't find
people that could even interview for
those jobs and I'm also a mom and I
worried a lot about my child's education
and were they getting a good enough
education that they could participate in
American society so I took a job at
Dallas iced tea 2012 so huge career
change
Dallas iced tea is a very large school
district roughly twelfth in the United
States we have a hundred sixty two
thousand kids there's ten thousand six
hundred teachers and we have a 1.6
billion dollar budget there's 233
schools but they're spread across 384
square miles including Dallas but many
other cities we have lots of challenges
right ninety percent of our students are
economically disadvantaged
I think we're second only to Chicago a
lot of people don't think of Dallas that
way 40% of our students have limited
English the demographics in Dallas are
very different from the demographics in
our public schools but demographics in
our public schools 70% Hispanic 24%
African American and 5% Hispanic ology
college-ready means they got a 21 or
higher on the a CT they got a 990 or
higher on the math and reading portion
of the SAT that's our definition of
college ready and that means they're
capable of taking an entry-level class
at a community college 14.4% and no one
can look at that statistic and say okay
we're doing a great job so one of the
things that's really puzzling though is
the Dallas ISD has
some of the best schools in the nation
year after year our magnet schools are
at the top of the list so clearly we can
get it right we just haven't got it
right across the board this is a problem
that's been going on for decades this is
from 1980 the chaos must end it's a
three-ring circus only with five rings
so this is the culture and these
decades-long problem that we've been
going through when I started in 2012 we
began to ask questions how many
eighth-grade math teachers do we need to
hire no one could answer the question
well how do I answer that well you'll
have to call the principal's
well there's 44 of them well that's how
you get the answer how many of our buses
arrive on time what's the percentage of
on-time arrivals
oh you don't track that what percent of
our employees what's the attendance rate
for our employees they didn't even know
where the data was so simple operational
data that you would expect to be at the
fingertips of the superintendent of the
schools was invisible to him my job I'm
not an IT I took a job as special
projects officer I was focused on the
fires the things that he needed someone
like a SWAT team to focus on but over
time more and more often I ended up on
the data side one of the things that
really stumbled me was how many
businesses Dallas iced teas in we do
everything from real estate to custodial
to fleet maintenance imagine the
maintenance of school buildings we have
glaciers we have plumbers we have
electricians so there's this enormous
business that D is D is in but then when
I got to IT they only have 200 employees
87 are Desktop Services that means
they're out in the field helping people
with their laptops in the classroom 40
our network services we know what
they're doing so very few
people actually focused on back-end
systems we have to in TBS
they're both contractors that scares me
and this is where they work gotta love
that I've drove by it multiple times the
first time I went to visit it that can't
possibly be it but yet that's where our
operations and our IT folks work well
why is that you can't spend money on
things like that you need to spend money
on the classrooms that's way more
important so it's very hard to attract
people to come work for D is d in the
technical field would you want to work
there there's a hundred and twenty
student facing systems now remember to
DBAs 120 student facing systems and it's
generating an enormous amount of data
before I came there was a 14 million
dollar dashboard that was developed some
of the brightest minds in the industries
developed it but before I even arrived
it had been shut down from disuse no one
used it and there were reasons that it
didn't have a time dimension that's the
problem but it 14 million dollar failed
in January of this year the
superintendent came to me and said
Carrie you wrote the definition for what
we need in the dashboard and you did a
prototype can you just finish the
project and I said well what are you
sure I'll be happy to so that was in
January he has signed it to me
it took till April to actually acquire
the software that we chose to use that's
called QlikView my deadline was May we
made it so we released the dashboards in
May and we released them to the public
to our Board of Directors in June so in
four months we were able to go from
nothing to something I think it's really
powerful
the
as part of the data map kind of looks
like garbled e goop but those of you who
know you understand what this is about
I had to manually scrub every single one
of these so no one else could touch the
data and no one else I why is there a
record for employee absences and no
hours why is there hours but no date I
had to learn what caused all of those
things and fix the data in order for us
to be able to report on them so I think
you'll find it very interesting to see
what we came up with so this is a Dallas
is D performance management dashboard
has a hundred and twenty different
systems connected one of the things that
was really important was that you had to
be able to interact with the data so at
anytime you can make selections on data
and wherever you go that selection
persists so I just flipped from
college-ready on the first page to
enrollment statistics and we can see
exactly the enrollment at those schools
we can also look at locations so our our
schools are groped grouped by feeder
pattern and a lot of times there's so
many that it's really hard for me to
keep straight in my head where they are
and what feeder pattern they're in and
so this is the first time we've had an
interactive map that allowed us to zoom
in on schools and that was very powerful
and these are things that in our
industry we've seen for a long time but
none of this was available at the school
district level so we graphed all sorts
of things everything we could get our
hands on we graphed this is an example
of college readiness it was very
enlightening you know if you look at
some of these schools it's crystal clear
how troubled those high schools are this
is PSAT results now the ones at the
bottom does
the number-one high schools in the
nation but those at the top we have so
much work to get to do we did the same
thing for all sorts of things like our
state tests so we you can flip back and
forth between many years these are our
semester exams this is one of the really
interesting graphs that we did first
semester exams kids who passed versus
the kids who didn't pass second semester
what schools in other words they taught
really well kind of at the beginning and
slacked off towards the end and those
popped up really quick enrollment we did
a lot of studies on you know where kids
are going one of the really enlightening
studies where these are all of the
comprehensive high schools and these are
the transfers out so Green is a magnet
transfer out and yellow was just get me
out and so it was very enlightening to
see which schools our kids were fleeing
from and where what schools were
attracting our kids we also did a study
on discipline discipline was very
interesting there had been a report
presented for years it was in a book
came out every six weeks and it was
spread over so many pages none of these
correlations were obvious you can see on
our offenses where does it happen it
happens all at middle school and when we
move into the discipline which is the
consequences for those we began to see
you know where we had out-of-bounds
conditions this is just middle school so
I just selected middle schools on the
side it just selected all of them for me
and we can see what schools have
discipline issues and here's a school
that does a way more out-of-school
suspensions than in-school suspension so
they tend to go straight to the most
hardest discipline that they can and
they don't have serious
of steps in between removals by age
this is suspensions by age again you see
those middle school kids just pop out
I'll clear this selection for middle
school and you can see it against all
the rest of the kids
we have lost instruction time less
instruction time to me as any absence so
it could be of an excused absence and
unexcused absence or some kind of
suspension and then we plotted it
geographically and we were looking for
trends and we found some interesting
things it wasn't what we thought daily
attendance this was something that we
are funded based on that ad a the
average daily attendance for school and
so we plotted it over years and just
looking at high schools it was really
clear really quick that our problem was
attendance was primarily at our high
schools
one of the things that I talk about a
lot is how much time we spent preparing
reports for various entities before this
just to get enrollment of the school so
can you tell me how many kids are in
sixth grade that was very hard to do and
now it's something that's very simple so
I'll clear all the selections in the
past it took two or three days to get
that answer so let's say you want to
know how many kids are in sixth grade
now you have it and you want it in Excel
because you're going to use it somewhere
else that's it that's how long it takes
now you send that to whoever it needs to
be done so we just shaved literally 99%
of the time off of that one of the
hardest things we did was focusing on
our employees that data wasn't well
reported but some of the things that
really stood out to us this is new hires
I told you at the beginning we have as
much as 20% turnover in our teacher
ranks every year well imagine the job
that it takes every summer to replace
all of those teachers and you can see
that crystal-clear on our new hires one
of the other things we had read and seen
studies that talked about there was
chronic absenteeism in large urban
districts most teachers worked 178 days
and they're granted eight days of
vacation and yet when we began to graph
average days out per employee it's a
little bigger than eight so it held up
to be true the other thing that was
really interesting
get rid of my selections this giant
monday-friday trend I'm sure this is
something that's common but this is a
huge problem in education
so one of the things that was
interesting was that because I had
prepped all this data I
I could see insights I could see wait I
think this school must have cheated
there's no way that they went from the
bottom of the list three years in a row
to the top of the list in one year it's
just not possible or there's something
really odd going on in the school for
discipline we need to go check it out
that was obvious to me but it wasn't to
my users if you're a principal it's like
your hair's on fire all day long you
don't have a lot of time to do this if
you're going to focus on discipline then
going to this dashboard was something
that was good you could go in you could
see where you fared against other
schools but if you're just trying to
manage day to day what are my biggest
problems right now
you had to really pull it out of all of
these graphs and so one of the things
that we started working on this summer
and I know this is something you've been
doing for a long time but how do we pull
automated insights the things that I
could see how could we begin to pull
that out and report that to our
constituents and so we began with
automated insights and you know very
interestingly some of the things that I
knew obviously just started popping up
on our automated insights so what did we
learn we learned that there's no such
thing as too much analysis everybody's
like oh Carrie you can't put any more
visualizations there's like 250 in the
app but what I learned every single time
we didn't want something popped out that
we didn't know so we found that the more
that we did the better it was our users
don't have the skills to see the trends
the out-of-bounds conditions our
inconsistency so just doing the
visualization was not didn't solve our
problems we had to take it further we
couldn't take no for an answer can't
tell you how many times we went after
data they said oh you can't have it it's
in a PDF like we'll send me the PDF
we'll key it in and as soon as we we
just wouldn't take no for an answer and
we got every single piece of data in
there you know
really made a huge difference in how we
operated the skill sets were not on
staff in our organization I did most of
this by myself in many many late nights
lots of weekends and you know our two
DBAs were swamped they couldn't help me
and then we just didn't have any other
stuff to work on it the manual cleaning
was unbelievable
I mean it the to clean up the employee
attendance data which had never been
queried before took so many hours and of
course we learned we need more than two
DBAs I knew that but what did it change
we started thinking differently and then
of course to actually change things in
education you have to be courageous and
you have to take action so providing
access to information was key that it
wasn't available there were so many
questions she couldn't get answers to
those all those different systems you
had to be able to see it all at one time
having paper reports wheeled in on a
cart wasn't doing anything there were
lots of problems that were masked we had
to focus on the right issues there were
so many things that we had to do
so this think differently act
courageously became our motto and what
did it change they're calling the Dallas
miracle and for decades Dallas they
measure school districts in quartiles
and generally Dallas ISD has been in the
third quartile never moved out of it for
decades and in one year we popped into
the top of the second quartile that and
it's a result of lots of changes that
were supported by data and this is a
different way to look at it different
metrics that they're tracking going down
as a good thing so entering this year
this is my third school year entering
this year
we have some interesting and very
promising results we have 300 million
dollars in the bank it's a big deal now
our school district isn't operating in
the red if something happened and
funding stopped our school district
could continue to operate for three to
four months in the past on the first day
of school there were an enormous number
of vacancies teacher vacancies in the
classroom
in 2012 there 860 on the first day out
of nine 9600 teachers this year we only
had 14 huge change all of our kids eat
for free the at 90 percent free and
reduced lunch it was actually cheaper
for us just to feed them all for free
than collect money for that other 10%
there are lots of other accomplishments
that we have backed by data we took our
principals to performance pay and now
it's tied to their their compensation is
tied to their performance our teacher
excellence initiative which does the
same thing it takes teachers off of
tenure and puts them on performance pay
that was passed by our board in the
spring and it started this school year
we have you know Obama challenged
schools to speed up the internet so that
we could have communication speeds in
the classroom that were high and we did
that but we did 20 gigabytes the
classroom because we believe that
personalized learning is where our
districts going by 2020 we're going to
open four to eight personalized learning
schools next school year so this is very
important to us the other thing was
fence defense it was really important
that kids could not be inside the school
but near the school and get access to
the Internet in many of our poor
neighborhoods the kids don't have a
device they don't go home to a computer
and Internet
so we began in one of our initiatives a
one-to-one device where we sent it where
we're going to send a home with the kids
we also installed Wireless paid for by D
is d and a lot of high density housing
and then destination 2020 is our
strategic plan and we now have all these
benchmark data and we can actually
measure and I know that sounds like
they're not what you should do but it
wasn't available this is what our
teacher excellence initiative looks like
every kind of teacher has different ways
they need to be evaluated so this pie
chart looks different across the board
fifty percent is based on spot
observations how do you how do you
handle your classroom what is your
classroom management style are you
prepared so 10 spot observations or
formal observations 50 percent 15
percent based on student surveys that
was proven out through some scientific
research and then this rest of it is
based on student achievement but many
different metrics so not heavily
weighted to the state exams or the AP
exam but a mixture of things the other
thing it's really interesting is working
to pull the pay out so that our best
teachers can make a lot more money and I
think that's really important in
acquiring new people into our field and
to encourage the kind of professionalism
that we want so this year we're going to
focus a lot more on insights I showed
you a little bit of that this
personalized learning that's going to be
really important in it a lot of the back
end of what we do has to change you
think about schools it's all based on
semesters scheduling at a semester but
he said Algebra one has to take exactly
two semesters so we want to loosen up
the timeframe and allow kids to take as
long as they need to complete classes
one of the things we spend a lot of time
working on is equitable access
there's definitely not equitable access
to our bus teachers our best teachers
are in those magnet schools that are the
best in the country and we've got to
really work on how do we ensure that all
of our kids have an effective awesome
teacher teaching their class counselor
evaluations counselors are working with
our children on social emotional issues
but they're also the ones that counsel
them on what classes they should enroll
in evaluating those rigorously is going
to be very important coaching holding
our coaches get extra mentor for
coaching we need to hold them
accountable for what they're doing in
the past it's been you know okay you're
a coach and there was not a lot of
oversight we're taking our human
resources and our finance dashboards and
really diving deep so that we understand
lots of things that in past we haven't
even begun to think about this is what
personalized learning looks like to me
we think about all of these back-end
systems that I have to glue together and
all of these places where it's very
rigged it's very rigid maybe in time
that we have to bust through all of that
and so I spend a lot of my time thinking
about how we're going to take all of the
different things that we have and glue
them together to offer an awesome
education that's personalized to the
child based on where they are and I
think this is kind of the next great
step that we have to make and a lot of
the things that I think about is there's
so many curriculum on how to teach
photosynthesis and we know that possibly
that photosynthesis exercise works
really well with this type of kids but
not this type of kids you know think of
ranking that's pervasive in that other
industries we're gonna have to get good
at that
so I hope you'll all watch us as we
continue down our very brave and bold
path as we work to improve education in
Dallas